okay ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
if we could please take our seats it is
now six o'clock and we are set to let's
go would you mind
thank you very much um so good evening
everybody my name is peter richards i
will be chairing this evening's planning
committee for you i'm going to run
through a few housekeeping things have i
made to start with first of all if you
could please turn off your mobile phones
or at the very least into silent i don't
mind if you want to use them provided
they don't disturb the process and the
running of this meeting
and we're not expecting a fire alarm so
if you do hear one don't panic follow us
we will be meeting in the car park
opposite next to the windmill but um
hopefully we should be fine for that um
tonight's meeting is being recorded and
broadcast live so it'll be shown on
youtube and on the council's website
later on so please do be aware of that
um it is a meeting in public it is not a
public meeting so only those people that
are registered to speak will be invited
to do so when you are invited to do so
if you could make your way forward to
the chair on my right here the empty
chair there um
when you have finished speaking if you
could please anti-back your hands with
the anteback that's provided and use one
of the uh gel wipes just to give the
table a quick wipe down and the the
microphone quick wipe down that would be
great there is a bin just to the left
hand side of that table for you to throw
any rubbish into
um okay let's do some introductions so
first of all to my immediate right we
have ann banks from committee services
um online we do have our solicitor ross
chambers and our planners we have sarah
macpherson paul thompson stuart flaierty
and alice koznet alice is our planning
manager tonight and has a little
statement in making these thank you
chairman my role is to provide impartial
advice and to assist members in their
decision making
alex thank you very much indeed okay
let's move into our item agenda so first
of all do we have any apologies for
absence please
lovely thank you very much sorry my
microphone wasn't on apologies
from councillors adam and eddon lovely
thank you very much and um members do we
have any disclosures of interest please
counsel foreman first
um in item five i am the ward member
i've made no representations and
therefore will be participating with an
open mind
marvelous thank you very much councilman
mills
thanks mr chairman um on item one i i
did receive an email probably others
from
[Music]
doctors
tim and ellen clock regarding for
certification thank you thank you very
much i think we'll take it as read that
everyone has received i can see lots of
hands going up so yes everyone has
received that um while we're on item one
um some of the objectives are known to
me and uh i think it's best if i
leave the table and don't take part in
the decision making so i'm going to hand
over to the very capable counsellor
kendall for that item
um any other disclosures that anyone
wants to make
no okay jolly good minutes everyone
happy with the minutes from our meeting
on the 21st of july quick show home this
marvelous i'll sign those afterwards
okay so we're into our playing
applications so um first of all if i can
we have two applications where um we
have had they've been triggered by paris
council objection we have had no
registered speakers so in line with our
constitution and the rules of the
planning committee um i propose we bring
those forward and delegate them so if we
take first of all uh application 21 0 0
8 3 8 ful study football and social club
um i propose that we uh bring that
forward and delegate to officers could
someone please second for me thank you
councillor dixon we could have a show of
hands for those in favor please
is unanimous so then we will uh delegate
that to offices and similarly for
application reference 2100 950 ful
that's study football and social club
yet again i propose that we delegate to
offices could i have a second to please
councillor jennings and show our hands
please
unanimous once again thank you very much
we will delegate that
okay good right let's move then to our
first application which is the riverside
caravan park in tittington i'm going to
ask councillor kendall to come up and
take my seat
while officer sarah brings up her
presentation
okay then hello everybody right let's
get started on this one i just found the
right page in my agenda
bear with me a moment thank you so we
move then to item four uh which is
application reference twenty slash zero
two four eight nine slash ful
this is for riverside caravan park
diddlington road and it's the continued
use of land as caravan site um with a
variation of various planning
permissions
our presenting officer sarah mavis sarah
over to you thank you very much
this application concerns the riverside
caravan park on taddington road shown
here with the black dot
the application concerns parcel a which
is outlined in red on this plan parcels
b and c which are outlined in blue are
excluded from the applications so we're
just looking at parcel a
here we can see the site from an aerial
view
the application proposes to amend the
approved number of caravans and the
occupation period as given on this
comparison table there will be an
increase in period of occupation from
seven months to ten months and a
decrease in the number of caravans
permitted from 266 caravans to 180.
there is currently no restriction on the
ratio of static to touring caravans and
it's not proposed to impose a
restriction
in summary the proposal would seek to
increase the occupation period and
decrease the number of caravans
permitted on site and the application is
recommended for approval subject to
conditions as listed on page 16 of the
committee report
thank you sarah okay we go to our first
speaker on this mr clive griffiths
please
hello
welcome mr griffiths please do take a
seat
so you'll have uh three minutes to speak
we'll give you a warning in the last 30
seconds
uh yeah you just put it down towards in
this button in the middle to press to
turn it on
yeah
counselor there you go perfect there you
go lovely and if you'd remain seated at
the end for any questions from the
committee as well
sorry you'll have to you have to help
because i'm a little bit mutton jeff
sorry all right if something you'd
remain seated at the end for any
questions okay in that case over to you
okay
this proposal means that i will be faced
with a solid wall of the elevated static
caravan homes their windows and
balconies looking directly into the rear
of my home for 12 months of the year
within only partial shielding by summer
foliage this proposal is simply the best
example i've ever seen
of a wolf in sheep's clothing it has
been a modified late in the process
after consultation reports were complete
from
camper vans on grassland used over to
full year parking of large static
residential units which will require two
acres of concrete foundations to
integrate and integrated services it
will be a village within a village
the apparent offer of reducing the
number of units on site is a shaman a
hoax the threat of putting 260
residential units in the flood flow
route was never a viable or a financial
option
or else it would have already happened
the site's existing statics are
predominantly on higher ground
now the true nature of the proposal is
clear
planning permission therefore should be
required for a realistic realistic new
layout with details of foundation hard
standing roadways trenches
an assessment of neighbor implications
and landscaping
archaeological dig as it's next to a
scheduled ancient monument detailed
environmental
flood risk analysis
and more none of this exists
the nzo report offered
by haven estates was clearly written
without the knowledge that within four
years all units on site would be
in position for 12 months of the year
it states no increase in impermeable
services
again two acres of concrete bases and
half a mile of tarmac roads
no change in operational development
there will be a change from movable
camper vans on grassland to permanent
residents with pipe services and car
parking
all that changes is the number of
caravans to be generous the overall
occupation rate for the seven months is
circus sixty percent the proposed actual
band days on site goes up by thirty
percent so increases
traffic on the tidington road
it states the latest flood in this area
was in 2007.
that's a joke it actually floods twice a
year um and it flooded this christmas
and i've stood with nick who's on next
in the in that floodplain trying to stop
caravans floating down the river the
people profile using this site would
change dramatically from passing
tourists in campervan
sorry
she wouldn't stop me
the people profile using this site will
change dramatically from passing
tourists and campervans spending money
in town to one of uh residents of
retirement age
this is a hybrid proposal that slipped
past the planners a late change from the
campervans on grassland to large
elevated residents and two acres of
concrete foundations located in the
principal fast current flood route
this has not been evaluated the new
retirement village within a village
achieved under
now radar time has elapsed apologies
i've given you an extra 15 seconds
because of the interruption but i'm
going to have to stop you there i'm
afraid
you interrupted me i know and i've
accounted for that by giving you a
little how many seconds did you give me
an extra 15 seconds in fact so i'm glad
to pause you there i'm afraid um and
we'll go to the committee to see if we
have any questions for you any questions
from the committee
yes councilor mills
yeah yes good evening um the reduction
of these
caravans
um
would that lessen the problem for you
know for the view that is no not at all
it uh they're they're located at the
base of my garden on elevated
platforms because it's in the principal
flood flow uh route and as such uh the
the reduction in vans there will still
be right across the
end of my uh garden
so and so
normally the the canvas would would come
and go correct but these are
taken there these are static uh
constructing a more or less a dam across
the river
because this route where they're going
to be placed
the river
in flood changes route it goes directly
through this path
and it is fast flowing as we've seen in
the last 20 years every couple of times
a year so these vans are being placed
directly in line
with a fast-flowing flood
and it has not been evaluated
thank you very much thank you my
pleasure
do we have any more questions
from the committee
okay in that case mr griffiths thank you
very much for your time tonight much
appreciated wait a minute if you'll just
give it a bit of a wipe down for you
thank you
okay
thank you we'll go to our next speaker
please mr nick allen
thank you councillor curtis much
appreciated
mr allen welcome
hello there
so the same rules apply for you uh three
minutes i'll give you a warning in the
final 30 seconds so you know to wrap up
and if you'd remain seated for any
questions at the end please thank you
okay it's over to you thank you our
counselors thank you very much for uh
hearing us tonight we were here last
month when it got deferred so
appreciated how quick it's come along
and we can get into this meeting
my name's nick allen i'm the owner of
avon rayford and riverside holiday park
um we're one of the largest visitor
accommodation facilities in stratford
with around 80 000 guests each year and
28 full members of staff
plan permission to operate a car on top
of the other side dates from the 1970s
there is no planning condition to limit
the type or number of caravans used on
the land
so we can actually have statics now that
would be there 365 days a year
the currently has a mix of touring and
static caravans
we did a certificate of lawfulness to
demonstrate the physical capacity to at
least have 260 carbons however our
company is limited by a planning
condition
to seven months of the year
during the last 18 months a year with an
increase of people staying in the uk for
holidays demand has increased for better
quality accommodation and week-long
bookings
on the other hand there has been a
decrease in touring carbon bookings at
stratford-upon-avon
accordingly this paying application
seeks to limit the number of caravans on
site to 180 whilst increasing the period
of occupancy from seven to ten months
this trade-off will equalize a flood
wish to holiday makers less studies
holla holobacos and there is no
objection from the environment agency
there will be no change to the caravan
site boundaries or further development
of roads and harsh annual buildings that
we're allowed to have now
visual impact will reduce because fewer
caravans will be spread across the site
a longer holiday season will provide
many public benefits
riverside will employ more staff for
ground maintenance cleaners and
management
clubhouse income and staffing would like
to increase and a longer season a higher
opportunity rate will benefit the
tourism and economics of
stratford-upon-avon and tillington by
lengthening their season that we allow
to have holiday makers on
therefore i asked his support
and go with the office recommendation of
granting their permission
thank you mr allen um any questions from
the committee yes councillor trump
your name is simon um just a question
about the hard and soft landscaping um
obviously with it with the change of the
site and
obviously one of the neighbors has said
about the visual impact on his property
and what do you what details have you
got about the hard and soft landscape in
your proposal please
i'm uncertain what we actually we put in
for the the soft landscaping scheme is
that best for the officers so perhaps we
pause that come back to it later
yeah that's fine yeah okay i'll speak to
the officer or not
yes councilor mills
thanks mr champ uh good evening stranded
um the um
obviously there are some opposition to
this application did you go into any
public consultation or did you have a
consultation with the parish council at
all
before you went ahead our council is
stratfor town council who deal with that
we we didn't on this application though
you didn't okay thank you
thank you council jennings
a simple question how essential is this
to the viability of your business
this changes the dynamics of what we'll
be offering as a caravan park
um
tours have decreased there's been over
the last 18 months a lot of um new parks
cropping up the the government have now
put in that there's the new 56 day wall
where you can have caravan parks
anywhere for 56 days so we've definitely
seen a downturn in that and what we're
finding is with the staycation um there
is a big up upturn in people wanting
better accommodation for for three or
four days or for week long
and we need to move with the times
we have the permission to station the
caravans that we want to put on
for 365 days of the year it's the
extension of the season that will help
us and hopefully help the communists
when even
well if there are no further questions
mr allen thank you very much for your
time as well tonight
if you'd give the table a wipe down and
sanitize it's fantastic thank you
i'll go to our next speaker council rolf
ward member
welcome counselor off
thank you for before i start i'd like to
thank this committee for
delaying this to allow me to be here i
shouldn't be here
but having spent 18 months on this
application with the residents i felt it
only fair to them and to myself that i
represented them properly and fairly so
thank you very much for allowing me
to do this you you are very well um
burst in the routine so over to you i
think
thank you um
the residents of teddington do not want
180 static caravans for 10 months of the
year
and would prefer the status quo which is
266
touring caravans which will come and go
over a period of seven months
in each year and here is why
180 static caravans for 10 months
occupancy a year
this will still mean that there will be
a hundred and eighty static caravans in
position for a whole year
sitting on a platform
floodplain with tarmac car parking for
two cars per caravan the status quo is
caravans coming and going to stay for a
short period of time anything between
one week and seven months with one car
at a time
the occupants of 180 static caravans
will not pay council tax but we use all
the infrastructure we as residents use
roads doctors and dentists postal
service and the care services
these are already
overstretched the likely age profile of
static caravan occupancy is older the
occupants up to 266 caravan using the
park anything between one week and seven
months will not be using such services
these temporary occupants will bring
vibrancy to the village and increase
tourism in stratford and surrounding
areas
i noted that nick allen said that they
can have statics if they want to
for seven months um but it actually
doesn't make economic sense for them to
do so so it's mostly touring of people
for short periods of time because it's
only seven months people are not going
to live there for seven months
um
it is also worth noting that tourism
visitors to the caravan park will use
the local village shop and restaurants
and the local pub on a more regular
basis and will venture into the town and
the surrounding villages as there will
be visitors and are likely to be on
holiday
ten month permanent residents will not
use the facilities as much
and behave like we all do where we live
10 months of static caravan occupancy
will have a detrimental effect on the
economy of the village and town in
particular as there will be nowhere for
the touring caravans to go
tillington businesses rely on the
trading caravans throughout the spring
and summer
180 static caravans will increase the
occupancy
of the village of tiddington by at least
a third i spent the past 13 years as the
local ward member protecting tittington
as a village separate to stratford with
its own identity spreading and
increasing the numbers loses its unique
identity
you are being persuaded by the planning
department that 180 is better than 266.
you have to understand that 180 static
caravans will be sited on a flood flow
pathway all year round exacerbating the
increase in flooding
266 will not have that effect as the
caravans will come and go and there will
be less tarmac for statics and car
parking
the latest flood was in 2007 this is not
correct the flood flow pathway on the
caravan site floods regularly in fact it
was 2016 when residents further down by
the river had to be rescued
with the current climate change
initiative this council has adopted i
would consider it to be dangerous for
this committee to allow this proposal to
go forward knowing that flooding is an
ongoing issue only getting worse year on
year
you have heard from a resident uh
recently regarding the effect of
flooding on his property you also need
to realize that next to him is reading
court which is a care home
they are terrified that this will
increase the impact on flooding on their
care home so please be aware of that
situation
the visual immunity to those residents
who live close by and those who drive
along the tidington road will be
seriously affected by the onslaught of
static caravans sitting on tarmac with
their cars by them not to mention
visitors it will be an eyesore
this proposal has absolutely no support
at all from all the residents of
tiddington
this was pointed out to robert weeks and
david jeffrey a few months ago when
residents and myself had a meeting to
discuss this
we ask that you as a committee have a
site visit so that we could show you all
the detrimental effect this proposal
will have on the village sadly nothing
has come of it and this report is still
stating that because 180 is lower than
266
then it is better it is not better in
any way as stated above there are enough
planning reasons to refuse this
application flooding economic
development and dis benefit loss of
visual immunity
infrastructure overload i cannot
emphasize enough how much the village of
tiddington and the residents on the
tittington road do not want the
application approved it will change the
village beyond recognition and have a
huge structural
effect on the lives of those living on
the tidington road and the village of
tiddington do not approve this and
therefore allow the status quo to
prevail thank you
thank you okay
we just had
oh dear
right right okay do you have any
questions from the ford member yes sir
council dixon
cathart you mentioned the care home yep
um i'm looking at a map um i don't see
where about it is i'm sure you can tell
me whereabouts on this little map in our
planet it's called reading court if you
show me a map i'll show you exactly
where it is
this doesn't help at all um
it's not on that one
council dixon do you have a question a
follow-up question on this yeah it was
it was it was local knowledge it was
actually next to this gentleman's house
it's just there
and it's further down into the
floodplain might be one we come back for
a point of clarification
if the officer's gonna die
lovely
so you can see council dixon how close
it is right where is it
okay thank you lovely stuff
um council gems
thanks jim
uh council royal fear you said that
obviously we know that they can have 266
static caravans there now
but you said that people aren't going to
want to live there if it's only for
seven months of the year but obviously
this is a proposal for 10 months of the
year
what makes you think that people will be
prepared to live there for 10 months of
the year
but not seven and
so this this eight weeks gap
i especially with old people and it's
going to be difficult to find an
alternative place to live for eight
weeks of every year
but they do
they do find an alternative gap for
eight weeks but try finding somewhere
for five months it's impossible that's
why it doesn't make any economic sense
for people to live there for seven
months you'll find that most caravan
parks across the country do not have
people living permanently for seven
months they come for a period of time
they come for two weeks come for one day
they come for perhaps the whole of the
summer because they can but they don't
come for seven months because they have
to find somewhere else to live for five
months doesn't make sense
okay thank you
okay any further questions for the ward
member
no that case council role thank you very
much for coming tonight thank you very
much
okay um committee let's uh move to
points of clarification from the
officers do we have any questions
yes counselor grant yeah thank you mr
chairman yeah um sorry sir um question
about hard and soft landscaping there
was obviously concerns from the
neighbours and um
the views from diddlington road as well
um
just wonder
what was proposed and
obviously yeah landscaping can take a
while to
fully yeah so if you refer to the
proposed conditions which were on page
16 of the committee report condition 7
requires that prior to implementation
hard and soft landscaping will be
submitted and approved by the local
authority so that will come to me for
assessment
and condition 6 also would require a
site layout plan to be submitted and
improved and that would include
any parking areas roads circulation
infrastructure so that's basically all
hard standing and also worth noting at
condition three that we are conditioning
parking spaces to be permeable that's a
recommended condition i would say um
so yeah just worth bearing in mind those
conditions on page 16.
yeah
thank you council curtis
thank you um
yes i'm i'm just slightly confused
um as well just me on on page 14 again
back to the hard standing
in the
third paragraph down under water and
environment and flood risk it says um
it's important to remember this
application does not propose any
alterations to the existing
levels of hard standing
but then in the fourth paragraph in that
same section
it says um it's noted that should the
applicant decide to increase the
proportion of static caravans on site it
may increase the hard standing
and my understand my understanding is
that
all of these proposed 160 or so caravans
would be on hard standing
could you clarify that yeah so what's
important to note is that there is
currently no restriction on the ratio of
static to touring caravans at the moment
the 266 caravans which there is a lawful
development certificate
saying that they can have can be static
or touring in any combinational ratio
um
and the sort of associated stuff that
goes with that um so this proposal is
seeking a reduction in number it's not
seeking any alterations to the physical
things on the ground that can be
controlled by condition
but
at the moment
um
none of the static caravans are on hard
standing
so are we are we actually looking at a
considerable increase
if this proposal were to go ahead in the
in the amount of hard standing that's
what i'm trying to sort of clarify this
application is for a use of land and the
use of land at the moment is for
caravans whether touring or static and
the proposed use of land is for caravans
whether touring or static it would be
assertion to say that they will become
static caravans and that they are at the
moment touring caravans because in
either situation whether this permission
is approved or refused they can have
either we're simply looking at the
number and the occupation period the
makeup of static or torah doesn't come
into the consideration of the
application because at the moment they
can have either and the proposal seeks
to have either um
so
that's the difficulty is that it's a use
of land it's not permission for
these specific caravans it's the use of
land that we're looking at which is why
it kind of is tricky to get your head
around
sorry that still doesn't answer the
question about
it will there be a significant increase
in hard standing because i think that is
relevant as this is flood plain
yeah and
um i i think the important thing to note
is i think sarah has picked up on on the
numbers point and the um difference
between static and tourers i think the
thing is obviously we're comparing
two situations which we don't know
because they do have extant planning
permission to implement and place 260
caravans whether static or torah on the
land what they're proposing is less
caravans we in reality we don't know
what extensive hard standing they would
require if they wanted to implement that
260 planning commission so we can't as
officers say that the extant permission
would result in more or less hard
standing than what they're proposing now
but what we can say is that we've got a
condition on this application which
would give us an element of control to
check how much hard standing they're
proposing and whether it's appropriate
the difference is that the extant
planning permission doesn't have any
such conditions so we have no control
over the extent of hard standing by
granting this with that condition we're
giving ourselves that element of control
thank you thank you i'd also say we've
had no objection from the environment
agency their comments are in the report
with regards to flooding councillor
dixon next
i think it might have just been covered
but it's he my question was going to be
given that they have permission now for
any combination of tourers or statics if
they wanted to
put
20 statics on a currently grassed field
they wouldn't do so presumably without
creating some hard standing for that
would they need planning permission to
put that hard standing in or could they
simply put 20 statics now
on hard standing in a field without on
the basis that
they could have aesthetics or tourers
our viewers on the basis of the extant
planning permission being in place they
could they could do that tomorrow and
because we don't have that condition to
tie in the hard standing they could put
down basically whatever hard standing
they desire
okay
thank you um council jennings
sorry councilman mills apologies sorry
castle james uh mr german i think my
questions answered about the heartstring
thank you
right uh no further points of
clarification we should go to the debate
who wants to kick us off
don't call russia
council dixon thank you
thank you chairman um i hear exactly
what uh has been said and concerns
regarding flooding etc um however
the environment agency are not raising
any objection they know the extent of
the floodplain and the frequency of the
floods and the dangers of flooding etc
essentially what we're being asked to do
is to give permission for
uh
usage of the caravans from seven months
to ten months and i can't see any
planning reason to be against it as such
so i would propose that we accept the
officer's recommendation
thank you council dixon council jennings
councillor dixon has stolen my thunder
and that's exactly what i was going to
say
um at the moment so they could put 266
static caravans down with as much hard
standing as they want they've got free
reign
um
if we
if we if we grant this we can put robust
conditions down on it and we have
and we have a lot more control about
what will happen to this
um
what to me is really really relevant is
the fact that there's been no objection
from the ecology from the flood
authority
um
and they're the experts
and so i'm more than happy to second the
proposal
thank you captain jennings uh
cat was anybody else wanted to speak
capsule mills thank you yeah thanks
richard yeah um
i'm just a bit concerned about the
flooding um
i mean who's right who's wrong i mean
the residents i mean they're
clearly adamant that they're it in a big
way and destroyed every was affected
1998 and 2007 and they're saying it
floods
um
you know during the year so who's right
who's wrong um i i
i always get where always
i probably would support the residence
on this mr chairman thank you
thank you councilman scott's answer
servant thank you sir
yeah i have concerns of um the amount of
hard standing
which would increase the flood risk
and also
there never seems to be
enough thought going into the objectors
who live in this village
because this is quite a considerable
amount
extending this caravan park on a flood
plain and
i'm not happy with it at all thank you
okay
if there's no one else wishing to
speak
i'll add my thoughts as well i think
although i do have a lot of sympathy for
the residents and all the objectives
like cancer dixon said i can't see any
material grounds to
not grant this
um i completely understand but i think
this does give us that that element that
measure of control
and as we've already heard that if if
they wanted to do tomorrow if they
wanted to build these you know put these
static vans in tomorrow they could do
that and we'd have no control over it at
all
so reluctantly i will be voting to grant
as well councillor crump did you want to
speak yes sorry mr chairman um
yeah this is quite a difficult one um
and i obviously raised my concerns about
landscaping and the effect on the
neighbor
and hopefully um the officer will will
take that into account when the
application if the application is
approved and the scheme comes in
um more the concerns were highways this
doesn't seem to be anything from the
highways regarding
accidents etc
and they've not objected um
there was issues
concerning uh flooding and again
um
i i totally sympathised with with the
objectives where on the flooding because
um often the agencies seven trenton
environment agency don't know
the the details and and i do find that
one sometimes really difficult to
um
to take into account shall i say um so
that is very difficult my only concerns
i will say so
it's interesting that the town council
haven't put any representations in
um which i thought they might have done
but they didn't and this
whilst i see there are a reasonable
number of objection i think 10 letters
of objection
and again i would have thought there
would have been more
letters of objection for something that
was so contentious so
um that's my con my my concerns and i
would tend just to go with officer's
recommendation but have concerns about
landscaping and if there's anything can
be done to ensure that the flooding
situation is mitigated um i would like
to see that as well if possible thank
you
it's cat's fault
thank you um i would echo those views as
well i have um sympathy for the
residents but um i do think that
having some control would be better than
the situation they've got now with no
control and perhaps is it possible to
have a condition that would help protect
the gentleman's property from with the
view
tree either
yes sir um yeah so hard and soft
landscaping that is a recommended
condition that would include boundary
treatment and so yeah i can certainly
bear that in mind and if members wanted
to suggest an alternative word into the
condition or something like that then
that's something that's within their
gift to do
thank you
uh do do we anybody do we want to do
that do we want to suggest any
additional wording or perhaps a note to
go on that
okay
yes council mills
sorry apology
thank you chairman and i think
what may be preferable from from my side
and from officer site if you agree would
be to put some sort of note on to set an
expectation that we would expect an
element or special consideration to be
given to the immunity of neighbouring
properties in designing any sort of
forthcoming landscaping scheme i
wouldn't necessarily want to amend our
sort of standard condition wording but
absolutely a note i think is is a good
idea
thank you i think i'd agree with that
too
um right i think we're
check out the curtis go for it so thanks
jeff um
i am
a little concerned i i suppose one of
the
concerns about is this going to be the
quasi fully residential
site
i know and we have to obviously look at
the application in front of us but just
looking at page 13 of the office's
report and the site would remain in
holiday use and the units would not be
permitted to be in anyone to be anyone's
sole or main residence
as such it is important the site remains
in holiday use only
as is proposed this would necessarily be
secured by planning condition
i think would i would like to see
real strong reassurance that these
conditions would be robustly enforced
and i wonder actually
how practical it is
just on the ground with the resources
the council has to ensure that people
are not staying more than 10 months and
using it as permanent residential
accommodation
i'm not sure which one of you wants to
answer that particular point
i'd tip in and say that the conditions
have been drafted with the advice of the
enforcement team on what is the best
condition to use to secure the outcome
that it will be enforceable for holiday
use only i've received advice that this
is the best condition to use
and we would run any final wording
passed an enforcement officer before
issuing the final decision
and that you know this is the preferable
condition um for the enforcement
department and
to ensure that it remains in holiday use
only yeah
council mills
uh so the occupancy restriction would be
limited to 10 months yes
occupancy of the caravans it doesn't
include um you know access to the site
or the clubhouse or any of that
ancillary stuff but no one will be out
allowed to occupy the caravans yeah but
one asking is will the site be closed
for two months or not
the condition wouldn't require that as
well i'm not about the condition i'm
just asking if it's going to know so it
could be a they could be someone there
12 months of the year i would imagine
there'd be some sort of ongoing
maintenance but i think that's you know
somebody would live there
you know people could live there
not the same people obviously the same
people but they could occupy that site
for 12 months of the year no one could
under this condition no one could occupy
those
the caravans on the parcel that we are
talking about for those two months of
the
two months isn't year yes yes
yes
okay
right
we've talked about it a lot i think we
should probably go to a vote on this um
of course it's been proposed already and
seconded um we need to confirm that the
proposal and the second are okay for us
to add those that note you're happy and
okay second is happy okay so the
proposal then is to grant with the
conditions that we mentioned plus the
additional note regarding landscape
all those in favor please show
two three four five six and all those
against
one
not two and any were there any
abstentions no attention
yes
let's do that again all those four
let's keep it clear
okay six okay those are gates
three okay so there are no extensions
okay in that work case the committee
resolves to grant application reference
twenty slash zero two four eight nine
slash f u l
and i'll vacate the chair and allow
council rich to take over again we'll
just pause for a minute thank you
that's a kendall uh and banks has just
said she actually rather you were here
all the times
not the greedy it's not the greeting i
was hoping for okay there we are thank
you very much for doing that members
let's move on to our next application
which is item five um application twenty
one zero zero four four five f u l
that's hazel grounds and great on our
presidential conferences once again
sarah mcpherson sarah whenever you're
ready
okay thank you chair uh
this plan shows the location of the
application site located by the black
dot
within hazel
the application site is outlined in red
on this plan and is
accessed off pelham lane the listed
farmhouse and associated structures are
seen in red that's printing the road
with the application site to the rear
the existing site comprises a cattle
shed which is the subject of this
application and is proposed to be
demolished it benefits from an extant
class q permission for conversion into
five dwellings
there is a detached modern barn
um on the site which is also going to be
demolished
the listed farmhouse and existing vile
conversion are shown sort of to the top
right of this plan
here are the existing elevations for the
cattle shed which is going to be
demolished
and this is the proposed site plan the
proposal is for a total of five units
arranged in a
courtyard layout the access would be
from pelham lane and a turning and
parking area will be provided within the
site
there's also a detached carport and
store
between unit 5 and the existing barn
conversion
here if you can see my cursor
so these are the elevations on floor
plans for plot one all of the units
follow a very similar design scheme so
i've not shown them all but i have them
as reserve slides should you want to see
them
um the units would be there's four
proposed as three bedroom and one
proposes two bedroom
turning to site photos this photo is
taken from pelham lane and it shows the
list of buildings including the
farmhouse which is um to the back of the
photo
this site photos taken from within the
site looking towards the back of the
listed farmhouse
this is a view of the large farm cattle
shed within the site
and panning to the left of the cattle
shed
and this is the modern barn which is
also proposed to be demolished
that's it
thank you
sarah thank you very much uh let's move
to our first week on this item who is
counselor martin grieves of hastel crash
council if you would like to make your
way forward please
good evening council cruise thanks for
your patience while we work through our
agenda um so you probably know already
you have three minutes i'll give you a
30 second warning for your time is up
otherwise save it to you whenever you're
ready
thank you thank you for your time we
appreciate it um
we object into this on various points um
first as well also bring to notice the
cpre workshop um who said it cannot be
done anyway under their rules
um but if we're looking through the
actual application
um we
they're going to take 10 car parking
spaces
um those 10 spaces are going to run past
a listed building
um i don't know how that's actually
going to be done the waste storage and
collection areas 21 bins which they
propose to put in a building next to the
road
21 bins next to the road is actually
incredible
um they say there's no increase in
occupancy but yes we've gone from 11
bedrooms to 14 bedrooms on the two
different plans from the queues so new
ones that's the 27 increase in occupancy
so clearly we're going to get more than
10 cars there
because if you have 14 bedrooms the
chance is you're going to get 14 cars
plus
site visits they say that you cannot see
from public footpath which is not true
if you walk down from the hazel church
um which is a path all the way down you
can actually see this property um in its
in its
glory
um
they say other people say they can't see
it as well um i noticed that the only
people really that
have agreed to application
is roger and barbara walters who
obviously previously owned the property
um there's been a plane applications
over the last few years it would appear
that every time they get an acceptance
on an application they just put another
one in to make it even bigger and bigger
and we're just wondering when this is
going to stop
um and we have already seen the problem
with drainage this this property floods
on a regular basis um all the way down
to the river it's it's we walk our dogs
down there and you can't do it
they're also looking to put chippings
onto the onto the area so you've got 10
to 14 cars chucking chippings onto the
road and these as most people know it's
a cyclist route uh the chance of a
dangerous cypress accent down there is
pretty big along with obviously the car
issues
that's our main concern thank you very
much
council grief thank you very much well
within your time um members do we have
any questions for the parish council
please
no uh councillor crump
thank you um again obviously
this as a prayer counselor you obviously
do great work and volunteer and put
yourself in front of the community um
obviously i assumed that it was
unanimous or you you'd got a majority
committee to eject against this
i know there's only one letter of um
there's no letters
from local residents objecting
that was a cpre isn't it
one letter of support and one letter of
no representation of no objection the
only letter of objection came from the
cpre um yeah you could just explain
why the paris council feels like this
yet the rest of the
parish
agreed um it was unanimous that we
actually we took this on um the
residents have all come to us
independently um it's a very world cup
hazel is a very leaky village um they do
believe that if they were to put an
objection into the thing um against a
normal person uh that could be taken
against them so most people have sort of
given it to their parish council to take
on board but i i totally agree there'd
be more objections we might not be
sitting here tonight yeah
okay thank you any other questions from
parish council please
no in that case council grieves thank
you very much for your time if you could
give the desk a quick wipe that would be
really appreciated and while you're
doing that i will ask our next speaker
to make their way forward so we have our
applicant next which who is mr matthew
holder mr holder if you'd like to make
your way forward
thank you very much
so mr holder you also have three minutes
i'll give you 30 second warning make
yourself comfortable and whenever you
are ready feel free to start
okay
good evening my name is matthew holder
and i'm the applicant i also live in the
converted barn at the front of the site
with my wife and two young children
hazel the grounds is made up of two
distinct groups of buildings there are
traditional grades who listed
buildings which from the lane and then a
larger modern agricultural shed which
are cited immediately to the south it's
these modern agricultural sheds in which
this application refers to
we currently have we currently have
classic approval to convert the barn
into sheds into five houses this is
absolutely workable however the current
proposal for five new build houses
offers a number of distinct advantages
recognized and supported by the case
firstly
officer
moves development further away from the
listed farmhouse therefore improving the
setting of this listed building and its
outlook please note the support from mr
and mrs walters the owners of the
farmhouse
secondly the previously approved classic
use scheme proposes house fronts facing
each other at a distance of only eight
meters apart
the current proposal achieves a much
greater separation and ensures a much
more open aspect for each of the new
houses
thirdly this application scheme proposes
25 less volume of development than the
class q approval therefore increasing
the openness of the green belt
fourthly the proposed layout is more
reflective of the traditional farmstead
as it proposes traditional courtyard
formation with houses designed
sympathetically to the rural setting
being single story of traditional red
brick and with a stone-shipped courtyard
fifthly the scheme allows for more
usable private garden space than the
classic approval and lastly the
application scheme makes it much easier
to include sustainable features such as
air source heat pumps rain water
recycling whilst also being able to
accommodate higher levels of insulation
than the classic q approval of a lag
we note the parish council's objection
on the grounds that the scheme is too
large and out of context with the listed
buildings however i would like to
emphasize the scheme actually involves
one quarter less development than the
class q approval with less volume less
fall of space and of lower height
it also has a much more traditional
appearance than could possibly be
achieved by the conversion of the larger
modern buildings
the parish council has also suggested
the scheme would be highly visible
highly visible from the lands to the
south i would argue this is not the case
on the slide there you'll be able to see
it there
uh shows views available from the public
footpath which runs over farmland to the
south for site as you can see from
viewpoints a and b hazel grounds is
either not visible at all or only barely
visible 30 seconds
uh viewpoint c shows the nearest view of
the site from the footpath you can see
that views of the closest building are
still quite distant and as the officer
report notes the building to replace
this modern structure would be
significantly smaller and lower
please note the proposed site is not
clearly visible from any road only from
this small section of footpath
in summary we believe the current scheme
is a vast improvement on the classical
approval it offers a respectful and
improved design provides improved living
conditions for future occupants and
involves considerably less building
within the green belt we will therefore
be very grateful for your support in
this application thank you
spot on three minutes well done
members do we have any questions for our
applicant please
no
in that case mr holder thank you very
much for your time this evening
okay we've got no more speakers on this
item so if we could move to uh points
for clarification for officers do we
have any points of clarification from
our members please
no i'm gonna ask a quick one if i may so
we heard from um the parish council
there are proposed 14 bedrooms um
just can you remind me please what the
requirement in terms of parking is
according to our parking standards
versus what is actually being proposed
yep certainly
uh my account the approved class q
permission gives permission for 13
bedrooms um compared to the 14 proposed
here
um so this application would be four
three beds each requiring two spaces and
one two bed which requires one which
gives a total requirement of nine
parking spaces and they are proposing
ten
perfect thank you very much indeed if no
one else has any points for
clarification councillor foreman
could i just ask was the environment
agency um i couldn't see in the report
that they'd been consulted
i may have missed it
um i wasn't the case officer for the
application i'm just the presenting
officer so i can't be entirely sure i
wouldn't like to say um they haven't
given a comment and it is in flood zone
one so it wouldn't normally be our
practice to consult them we're not
required to when it is in flood zone one
okay thank you
okay in that case we're moving to debate
who would like to kick us off councillor
dixon first please
hey chairman
i must admit when i was reading this uh
report i was uh greatly concerned um
because obviously the green belt is a
very sensitive issue and the idea of uh
basically getting class q permissions
etc to convert and then basically saying
well i think i can come up with a better
scheme
um if we actually demolish everything
and start again um in the green belt
so i've had my
fears until i actually got
well into the report
and it was mentioned there by the
applicant and it was a bullet points
towards the end
which when i saw that the increase in
the openness of the green belt would
result in a 24.8 reduction in volume and
when we're looking at green belt
development we are often looking at
volume calculation and percentages i
thought myself ah
i wish i had been put in the first
paragraph um but essentially so with
that in mind it is a situation whereby
i'm prepared to propose that we accept
the officer's recommendation and grant
it however
i have had some issues this week
regarding a case in my award
where
pd rights
were proposed
when it came to here
on his previous application totally
it was refused it went to appeal
the inspector didn't put on any
conditions and the result is that pd
rights were re-established
here we have a situation
whereby
i see that with
not putting pd rights or removing pd
rights from these properties and i would
like to see pd rights removed from a
possibility on these
properties
is that viable
i'm going to ask our officers to come in
on that my gut feel is we need to have
good reason to do it otherwise i think
they probably would have done it um but
let's see what they've got to say
yeah counselor riches is right you have
to have good reason to remove them we
can't just blanket remove them we have
to sort of go through each one and think
oh well why don't we want them to have
extensions why i don't want them to have
porches and so forth we have to be quite
specific and we have to be
quite certain on our reasons why um in
the past um we have done it as a more
blanket approach and that has come back
to buy to set appeal inspectors um no
longer want us to do that and we're
having to be more careful now
so
while you have a little think about that
we will have a chat with some other
members and then we can come back to you
so i had cancer jennings next please
thank chairman
once again
everything i was going to say has
already been said
um in general i like class q to remain
as class q
but to me these still look look like
bond conversions and seem to be in
keeping and the height of them is
certainly reducing the height is
certainly an imp an improvement
um the fallback position means that
uh they're going to be dwellings here
come come not made
so
again
it's good to have a bit more control
over it and
but also say as long as we have the
conditions satisfying the drainage with
sudden trend the routing issues wcc
which obviously we've got
um and i'm happy to second the proposal
thank you very much cancer joining us
cancer candle next please
i'll echo what's been said i think um
for me really it all comes down to page
bottom page 21 but there's extant
permission here already um the what's
proposed seems to be an improvement on
what we have as next and
that says it all for me so i'm happy to
third it
and for what it's worth i'll forfeit
because i'm going to say exactly what
you just said cancer kendall council
curtis please thanks and
just back to the business of
pd rights
and
i'd like clarification on this if it's a
class q
there are no pd rights are there
correct yeah we as we discussed i think
that's that's the
issue that council dixon has picked up
quite rightly and
it it
maybe this is a bit of a sort of trojan
horse by moving from a class q
to approving this
then they would there will be pd right
so i would like to re if we can
really see a robust condition
on this that does remove those pd rights
because it was originally an extent
class q
permission
thank you
understood um
do you guys want to have a quick think
about that while councillor jennings
comes in or are you okay to come in now
yeah so i think we do have to bear in
mind that this proposal does represent a
reduction in terms of volume so i don't
think green belt would be a sufficient
justification for restricting pd rights
but i think you may have room on things
like visual immunity the styling is very
much
um sort of rustic let's put that you
know they look like a barn conversion
even though they're not um and that sort
of courtyard effect perhaps you could go
for visual impact of
um domestic alterations such as
conservatory's porches and stuff like
that normal windows perhaps you would
want to resist those and that could be
done but i don't think green belt is the
best argument i think you'd be better
with virtual immunity
okay um castle drownings you put a hand
up
i was just going to say especially that
if they're building 25
or 24 less
and with the small extensions which
which the planning officer would see in
reasonable if it was never to go into
planning application
it would seem reasonable to me
understood um
i've just had a note from sorry forgive
me my machine has been very slow i've
had a note from my solicitor who was
obviously watching online and he said do
we know which pd rights exactly members
want to remove so council dixon you want
to come in on that please thank you
chairman could i possibly have a picture
please which will indicate the
individual domestic cartilage of these
residences because obviously
pd rights to my mind if they are
available to them allows them to
cover 50 percent of their domestic
cartilage with conservatory or anything
else
so
where are we
is that unit 4 in the top left
yeah this is unit four here where my
cursor is moogling around and the
courtyard is obviously in the front and
the domestic cartilage is significant in
respect to number four
it could cover quite a large area there
and unit one in a similar situation on
that corner could also do significant
and i think both of those if they took
the maximum available would more than
cover the twenty
twenty eight point four percent were
actually trying to save
so personally i think it is a situation
where by pd rights should be removed
as a blanket
or i think i think i'd be i think for me
i'd be much more comfortable if we're
going along those lines to go along as
sarah outlined before and i don't know
specifically what those pd rights are
you might want to give it again i'm
quite happy to give it to officers to uh
word the condition for yeah you just
want to run through a game what it was
you said before just for the benefit of
all of us particularly yes so i think we
need to be specific on which units we
want to remove pd rights for and which
pd rights we want to remove if your
problem is without buildings on units
one and four we need to specify that um
and obviously there are there are a raft
of things that you can do under pd
rights you can do extensions roof lights
normal windows porches outbuildings
you know a bit of hard standing and it
is all
down to a lot of other factors as well
like where you can place them in your
garden which we need to bear in mind as
well and i think perhaps the best thing
to do is for
members to outline their concerns and
then officers can sort of
check back with the legislation and see
what exactly we would be needing to
remove to address those specific
concerns
okay so i think councillor dixon has
highlighted properties one and four
particularly um i
specifically i think you said extensions
and conservatories so that
um
you're comfortable with outbuildings i'm
assuming outbuildings when i'm referring
to those i'm thinking probably sheds and
things like that which no problems
you've got no issue with that no issue
with poachers
um dormers given it's a barn conversion
are they in keeping but you're happy
with that
okay so it's literally it's just
extensions if we could just come in on a
point of clarification the 50 cover of
garden area actually relates to
outbuildings for pd
pd for our buildings
so i just want to double check that
obviously you've made reference to
extensions to uh units one and four that
you would want removed um slightly
different tests in terms of outbuildings
being the 50 cover of garden just want
to check that you don't want to move pd
for our buildings for those plots i'm
not i'm not encouraging it at all don't
get me wrong just understanding
okay
because there's a because for
outbuildings the restriction the broad
limitation is 50 of the garden for
extensions they are limited by size so
is it extensions that you're worried
about or about buildings
or both
just
okay yeah counselor dixon while you're
speaking could you put your microphone
on please
with with units one and four um to my
mind if you covered half the garden with
a detached
office for working from home that could
erode quite a large chunk of the green
belt and if pd rights were permitted
those two plots could have quite a big
extension by way of an outbuilding for
our home office working and should that
be permitted
if i can just come back and you're
making reference to the green belt but
obviously as sarah previously advised uh
this is a 24
reduction of what's there at the moment
i appreciate that the way you're
thinking is that you
you know we're granting this one of the
reasons being of that reduction you
don't want that increased um but i think
perhaps going more down the visual
immunity route in terms of keeping the
building sort of traditional looking as
a reason for removing pde is probably
more reasonable because obviously the
built form is already there it's already
having that impact on the green belt um
that's i mean i don't know how how best
to sort of eloquent it more than that i
think in terms of steering around a
reason i'd go for sort of visual impact
rather than than green belt
i'm much more comfortable with it i'm
going to say chairman i was going to say
the officers know what i'm wanting so
ultimately
i'll leave it in the office's hands
i'm much more confident go ahead thrill
so just to sum up i think we've got
there in terms of removing pd rights for
extensions and our buildings to plots
one and four
and we can
draft something to that effect bear with
me one moment
okay we got there council jennings as a
second are you happy with what has been
put forward
i would have been happy with just as it
was but
i'll go along with it okay
good unless anyone else has anything
else they'd like to say we'll move to a
vote
no okay so the proposal is to grant uh
in london was offered in line with
officer's recommendation along with that
additional condition over pd rights
could i please have a show of hands for
those in favour
marvelous in that case committee
resolves to grant application 2100 445
ful as we have outlined
okay
let's move on to our next application
which is application
2101196 rem that's 29 london road in
ships and onstar our presenting officer
is paul thompson paul are you set up
ready to go or do you need a couple of
seconds
i'm hot to trot sure though isn't it in
that case whenever you're ready to
please pop it up on the screen and the
floor is yours thank you chair uh good
evening to you members ladies and
gentlemen
those of you left
um we are here in shipston on style
london road the way the route south of
the town uh we're on the left-hand side
of it if you're heading in that
direction
this is a reserve matters application
we've already granted outline
planning permission for
the principle of development and the
means of access
this is what the site currently looks
like you have a bungalow
roughly following the building line
the
scheme
is to
basically turn it into a cul-de-sac
development rather like
southwind gardens
here the meadow there
and wilkins close down there
um there are several others on that side
of the road uh the pro scheme looks a
bit like this
two semi-detached houses at the front
and two larger detached houses at the
rear
this these are the plans and elevations
uh
fairly
standard
uh design
and this is what it looks like from the
front
not a lot to be seen from the road as it
stands
lots of screening and vegetation
from the rear it looks like this
you can see to the left and right
neighboring properties there if i go a
couple of slides
um
as submitted these projecting gables
here
were
at the opposite ends of that elevation
so that's been changed to protect
neighbours privacy
um
finally this is a similar
development which is immediately next
door just to show what density is like
in the area
so tonight we're looking
to determine the appearance landscaping
layout and scale
we do have one update which is to say
that the county ecologist has reviewed
the amended biodiversity enhancement
management scheme uh he is happy
with what we've received and so we can
if members agree we can apply a
condition just to ensure implementation
of that my recommendation is to approve
chair thank you
well thank you very much indeed um we
will move to our first speaker on this
item who is councillor john denney from
ships and tower town council that's it
do you come on forward please
my pleasure welcome and good evening
thank you for your patience i think
you've got an idea of the drill so three
minutes i'll give you a 30-second
warning whenever you're already do feel
free to start
good evening councillors and committee
members thank you for your for the
opportunity to speak on behalf of ships
on star
and in support of objections from
neighboring properties
you will recall when outline planning
permission was given by this committee
shipston town council were assured that
our concerns would be addressed at the
remaining matters application
they are not
first need
shipstand has substantially exceeded its
housing allocation in the current local
plan
the latest housing needs survey which
was conducted this year
confirms the need for bungalows not five
bedroom houses
the density is too high the houses are
too big and not spaced in keeping with
neighboring properties
with respect they're nothing like at lin
uh settling gardens or furlong meadow
um
our written objections specifically ask
for the heights of the buildings to be
reduced
the two massive five-bedroom properties
are barely 1.5 meters apart with a
six-foot fence between them loss of
trees a considerable number of trees
will be lost the biodiversity
enhancement promised
a new mixed hedgerow on the version that
came out on the 30th of march
this has since been removed
similarly the orchard planting promised
to the introduction is not included
neither of these appear on the proposed
site plan
surface water periods of heavy and
sustained rainfall are increasing in
frequency and intensity
since our previous meeting we've had
flood heights more than three meters at
shipston bridge on at least five
occasions
the response to the climate change
checklist on the portal is token at best
potential for adoption of soak away
is not an answer to the concerns
the water bots only collect water from
less than half the roof area
the cmep item 6 is only an agreement to
agree the surface water runoff must be
attenuated not just controlled
discharge to sewers is unacceptable
there is no drainage plan in this
application
shifts in town council will not accept
that remaining matters have been settled
until the building heights and hard area
are reduced
more tree and hedgerows planting are
included and surface water attenuated
within the site
thank you
thank you very much well within your
time
members do we have any questions
okay uh fine go ahead
apparently we have a video ladies and
gentlemen
what you can see there is
uh sewage and water rising from manhole
cover
in wilkins clutch which is built in
exactly in a similar way to the one
that's being proposed
and what it indicates is that the
drainage water from the a3400
comes off i went through this in its
entirety at the out me
presentation
where this event affected both wilkins
close
and uh compton gardens um and those are
both
cul-de-sac developments of the type that
is proposed here and working
i'm going to have to stop you i'm afraid
because otherwise we're going well over
the three minutes that's been allocated
i have given a little bit of extra time
for you we've seen that video i think
it's been on loop three times there now
so we will move forward
members do we have any questions for the
parish council please council mills
hi hello good evening um i'm just
looking at that video um
where was that uh in relation to the new
build from this uh
that is that used to be
um
right let me go that used to be 43
london road i live at 41 london road
it's just next door to me effectively
on that site they took away a fine
gentleman's residence and they put in
six houses in a cul-de-sac development
at the time we pointed out to both seven
trent and highways
that the runoff water from the a3400
fills the sewers and causes surcharging
of the sewage system and that is a
demonstration of exactly what happens in
that situation
yeah as soon as you get a period of
intense rainfall
it fills up the sewage system and it
backs up on there
thank you very much okay do we have any
other questions members council jennings
it's at four i think you said 43 i think
we'll do that as part of the officer's
uh clarification please
councillor crump
thank you denny um
have you been in touch with um
simon trent about
that issue
yes and what is their view on the
capacity what was their reasoning behind
that um
they are extremely concerned about the
slow running of the highway drainage on
the 3400 along the entire length of
london road
and and they they recognize that as the
as the water level rises at ships and
bridge which it just during periods of
intense rainfall
the rising water level shuts the escape
flap on the on the sewage system at that
point and therefore it backs up and
causes the cause of the problem
okay and is there any other questions
for our counselor i think we will move
on
no
in that case council denis thank you
very much for your time this evening and
your patience if you wouldn't mind
turning your microphone off and giving
the desk a quick wipe that would be
great thank you very much thank you
members do we have any points of
clarification for our officers please i
think councillor jennings had one in
terms of location
if you could show us on a map roughly
where the the property was we were
looking at the video in comparison to
where this says
looking at it would be around
here
that's certainly where number 41 is
around there thank you cancer jennings
you happy with that
council dixon please thank you chairman
paul um i'll see in the uh final page
essentially after the conclusion you've
got the various conditions notes
outlined conditions
um
does that mean that the conditions which
are on the outline are definitely
included in this
or are they simply
mentioned by way of a note i wouldn't
want because i'm thinking about
water butts and ev charge points etc
which aren't mentioned within there but
obviously water bots must have been at
mentioned outline stage there's no
mention of ev points uh on here but it
may have been outlined as well so i'm
just wondering if you get picked up
by that note and how
um
[Music]
legally
enforceable is a note which simply says
outline conditions
well the answer to that is that the
outline permission is the planning
commission so they have to comply with
those conditions all we're looking at
here is details effectively so we can
impose additional conditions that relate
specifically to these matters
but all of the conditions on the outline
planning commission apply because it is
a planning commission
except in safari as if they've submitted
detail for example if they've submitted
details to discharge one of those
conditions the biodiversity enhancement
method statement would be an example
then we would essentially re reapply the
condition to say it must be done in
accordance with this rather than you
must submit it if that makes sense
cancer dixon you can ask what you like
if you turn your microphone on
can i ask if eb points were covered in
the outline because there's no mention
of them here yeah they
yeah they were
and we had yeah we had the usual water
boat spins
evcp that's that sort of thing thank you
anyone else cancer crump
mr chapman yes just um age 54 about the
um water environment and flood risk or
um i'll assume that's
from the li llfi i
look at the conditions and the
discharges is
as long as that is that they've got to
be satisfied before that condition is
that would be how it wouldn't
necessarily be the llf bay
anderson you might want to come here
because i think they only deal with the
major development as a rule
yeah absolutely so um we consult llfa on
major application proposals um but they
don't provide us with a response on
miners um so once we get the drainage
plant in we'll consult with our building
control department and make sure they're
happy if they have any objections
obviously if we can get it mended if not
and then we'd seek to approve that i
mean what i would say is that it is in
flood zone one so it's in the although
obviously we've had some information
from from the resident to show that
there is obviously a capacity issue
um it seems to me like it's an issue
with the existing area this planning
commission isn't there to fix an
existing problem i think it's bigger
than this application um and it's not
for this application to fix
um so i did just want to sort of clarify
that for the purposes of of members
decision tonight
thank you very much
just that i'll probably be bringing it
for my part i'd probably be bringing in
seven trent at that stage as well
whether they comment or not that would
certainly want to
get that from them as well
that's that was going to be my next
question as i presume that we're going
to consult seven trends at the state at
that stage um i'm glad you've agreed
with that um cancer mills did i see your
hand go up yes thanks mr um because
there's a concern of flooding it seems
to be all the time now
and we could report any conditions about
permeable
driveways and things like this for this
application or can't we do that
uh
so yeah we do we've got the the drainage
plan yeah which permeable which goes
into already i was going to and then to
answer your question on the
outline permission we also have the hard
and soft landscape scheme which you
would need
to cover
okay unless there are any points
clarification that needs to bring in
again uh bringing up i think we can move
to a debate
who would like to kick us off
if no one starts i shall pick on someone
casa jennings
well this is a this is a reserved
reserved matters application not outline
planning applications so they're going
to be houses here come what may
um
drain should be dealt with by conditions
um
so this is all about design and whether
it fits in the area and there are other
similar
proper other similar sites down the road
i don't see any design issues
i'm therefore happy to go along with the
officers recommendations
and
to say that we approve this application
i'm going to assume that is a proposal
to uh to approve
before we take that any further um i
believe that the initial outline
application didn't have a hard and soft
landscaping
uh condition so i i'm going to second
your proposal if you'll include that as
a condition i will indeed lovely stuff
okay does anyone else have anything they
would like to say i can't
try to call you counsellor then alice if
you'd like to come in
oh sorry i was just going to jump in on
that one to say that part of what we're
actually approving here is the
landscaping so um i'll say proving
determining
um
and we do have the the site plan that
they've submitted here does include
details of permeable paving and so forth
um so
i mean we can certainly
it's within your gift to impose an
additional
condition if you wanted more details or
uh different measures than what they've
proposed but i would recommend having a
close look at the site plan because
the it's annotated with um
annotations as you might expect to show
where the permeable surfaces are going
and
sorry paul could you bring that up
chester we've got it on the screen for
us now please
well you'll be able to make it out is
another question
can i zoom in here i can
modern technology so the the resolution
on this isn't isn't great
but that sort of text
at the bottom
there
is is annotations
um the
sort of the herringbone pattern is is
annotated as
uh permeable paving
um
yeah i could share that screen couldn't
i
[Music]
um
i think you might be able to see it
better
thank you sarah might be able to see it
better on
this
screen
so
got there in the end
so
as you can see here
frp
the the areas
annotated frp
which as i say is this herringbone
pattern
that you can see here
that's all
application
210119 rem
fabulous let's move on to our next
application which is 2101 285 ful um
this is green acre barn in napton road
in stockton representing officers once
again paul thompson paul over to you
thank you chair bear with me two ticks
okay
i am being told that we are having some
technical difficulties on the live
stream um apologies for anyone that is
watching live
um
hopefully it is back online now we are
going to proceed um uh
in a lot of things popping up on our
screens now we are going to proceed um
uh with the meeting as it is um
hopefully we will be able to resolve the
technical issue while we're going on so
paul over to you
thank you chair uh yeah i think we're
we're good now um so
this is this application is um for a
patch of land just outside the village
of stockton um
currently is a barn it's converted using
what will then
class mb permitted development rights um
to change it from an agricultural
building
into a
residence uh it was then
it was originally part of this farm to
the south as i understand it and was
sold off separately with that
prior approval and with the adjoining
land which is the land outlined in red
that land is is not huge but it's it's
big enough to
warrant some looking after and to
produce some hay and so the
building here that you see
is what's proposed to keep tools and
implements and hay and so forth
inside it'll be uh sighted a little way
to the north of the
converted bomb just behind it
materials will be
matching um and this is what it looks
like in person um so you've got these
sort of
uh zinc panels or similar kind of effect
panels
um and that will be reflected on the the
proposed building as well um you can
also get some sense of the scale of the
land it's big for a garden not so big
for a farm
um
it's an agriculture building my
recommendation is to grant thank you
marvelous paul thank you very much so
our final speaker of the evening is
councillor howard collison from uh who
is the chairman of stockton parish
council if you would like to make your
way forward
good evening and welcome again thank you
very much your patience uh you've
probably know the drill three minutes
i'll give you 30 second warning whenever
you're ready feel free to start thank
you mr chairman good evening
the main reason for stockton parish
council's
objection to this application stems from
its position on conversion of
non-residential buildings outside the
village envelope into residential use
it has objected to the conversion of
another barn in recent years which
resulted in permission being denied and
we've also objected to the conversion of
parts of a stable building on the nearby
farm that your committee refused but was
granted on appeal
in this case permission is being sought
to build a new barn only a few yards
away from a much larger barn that used
to be in the same field
it was less than 10 years old but deemed
to be redundant for agricultural
purposes and was given permission for
conversion about five years ago
the long-term need for a barn in this
position
um
or of this size has not been
sufficiently established it's proposed
to be approximately twelve meters by six
meters
with mains power a septic tank
to house a few tools necessary for
mowing the grass and cutting the hedges
and storage of a few other supplies
there is also an indication that parking
for four cars is being sought
the parish council is not convinced that
a field of this size will provide a
permanent justification for a barn of
the size required with the facilities
that are also included in the proposal
thank you mr chairman
thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for our parish council police council
thank you and
just for clarification um
did you say that
this conversion sorry this this new
building um this barn
has a septic tank as part of the new
building that's my reading of the the
paperwork with the application and for
parking spaces
attached to this new building
sorry and also the full parking
additional parking spaces attached to
this building yes yes thank you thank
you i think we'll probably double check
that with officers
um members do we have any other
questions for our parish council
no councillor carlson thank you very
much for your time and patience thank
you and thank you for watching the desk
down without being reminded
okay points clarification to our
officers i think we have one straight
away um can you confirm if there is or
isn't a septic tank and four uh parking
spaces are joining this or part of this
uh i believe the the counselor may be
referring to uh the application form
which says there are four uh parking
spaces on the site already their
existing spaces um
inside the building um the application
documents do refer to
a water bore hole that they're going to
be putting in on the site and some of
the plants associated with that would be
housed within the building
um i'm just
double checking i don't recall reference
with septic tank but
i have been known to be wrong
it's red of course of course of course
siege treatment plant is is the the
phrase they use
which uh is currently outdoors uh so
they're looking to
make it not outdoors so ultimately
there's already a serious treatment
plant they're looking to move it into
that
okay that clarifies me cancer mills
first yeah thanks oh um
is that right there are sort of washing
facilities in this and there's a
except where the um
council was um referring to i mean
you're saying you're saying there's a
septic tank and there'll be uh other
facilities in there for
will will there be a toilet or something
in there
well this this was the question i was i
was answering it there's yeah i think i
understand i'm sorry sorry there are no
um toilets and things like that intended
the the statement does say no water or
sewage facilities are planned although i
would have thought a water borehole
would be a water facility
i would confuse the kinds and thank you
council dixon please
thank you chairman paul
um
i see this one very much sort of almost
a legal situation um looking at page 63
the far the thing at the top came as a
slight surprise the requirement for a
building to be redundant or disused is
not amongst the criteria when looking at
conversions
obviously the parish council town
council is obviously concerned that you
know you build a barn ten years later
you convert it into a residence etc and
they're basically saying is this another
one coming along so you end up trying to
create definitions as to what is an
agricultural building what is commercial
agriculture and what is a small hopping
so my question is to start off with
do we have any definitions as far as
planning inspectors are concerned when
it comes to what is a small holding um
and what is commercial agriculture um
because obviously we're taking the view
that if it's commercial agriculture it
can be converted
after 10 years
and we're taking the view that this one
because we don't think it's large enough
are holding for commercial activity
we've got to regard it as a small
holding
now i wouldn't want to see an
agricultural building on a smallholding
converted personally in 10 years time
because of loose
legislation
or
um
i think you've asked your question and
we're going around a circle so i'm going
to ask paul to answer it
um well i can give you chapter and verse
basic paragraph uh w of part three of
the gpdo
um says that for the com for the um
purposes of that whole
section of the legislation about what
you can turn agriculture buildings into
they have to be used as such
as an agricultural building for a
business so unless they're making money
from it
essentially then or losing money i
suppose
then um it doesn't count as an
agriculture building for our purposes so
when you're looking at what is
essentially a very large garden shed
um
it doesn't count basically
quite aside i mean and that's without
going into any other um
making any other assessment about
whether this building specifically would
be eligible for in any other way i
haven't carried out assessments that's
not what we're looking at
chairman the only comment i've got then
is in the conclusion
we refer to it as
granting to with this in mind i find
that this agricultural building conforms
etc and referring to it there as an
agricultural building is that going to
allow us or somebody in 10 years time to
say you called it an agricultural
building it's a bit of a i see where
you're coming from because it's it's a
bit of a technicality it's for it's
still in agricultural use if that makes
sense so we would consider this to be
agricultural rather than residential
however
for the purposes of the legislation that
we're concerned about here about that
would allow it to be turned into a
dwelling for those purposes it wouldn't
be considered an agriculture within the
definition of agriculture building for
those purposes
i'm slightly concerned we're trying to
assess something that's not happened yet
10 years is a long time so let's assess
what's put in front of us now um which
is what we're here to do
cancer crumb so just to sort of are you
saying that it's a non-commercial
agricultural building
that would be an excellent summary
can you note that please an excellent
look
thank you counselor crump um okay unless
anyone has any further points
clarification we'll move into the debate
who am i going to pick on first
councilor mills
thanks mr chairman yeah um i went
unlocked at this and when it is a
bit of a statement this um this building
i have to say and
the the um
tool
shed or whatever you want to call it
behind will not be seen from anywhere
from the um
on the roadside i don't you know it was
there so um
i think all that's been said tonight
we've been reinsured by the uh the
officers i'm happy to go along with the
officer's recommendations chairman thank
you i'm going to assume that as a former
proposal yes mr chairman in that case i
shall formally second it i think paul's
presentation in the report is entirely
robust i'm very happy with it i need to
say no more
did i see a hand up over that site
no
in that case let's move to a vote so the
proposal is to grant application
full
2101
line with the office recommendation
please throw up hands for all those in
favor
nine nine and those against
and abstentions
in that case committee results to grant
application 2101 285 fql um do we have
any uh urgent business
none in that case members thank you very
much for your help this evening um
we will close meeting there cheers